[Musique]
merci y en aura trier ce type sème la
zizanie armé d'un micro et d'un fameux
culot il ferait battre la terre entière
son arme la délation la dénonciation
quelqu'un vous emmerdez quelqu'un vous a
fait chier vous avez quelqu'un ne veut
plus supporter ce calme année là ce
qu'ibm va vous venger écrivez nous et ça
marche
les frustrer les tromper les déçus les
jaloux et les autres balancez 4 les
petits copains avec bonheur fonction du
courrier je pense que c'est une
jouissance rares francky c'est toi que
j'avance aujourd'hui la voyons ne faut
pas gêner quand même on perd
difficilement les vieilles habitudes
j'en reçois donc une centaine de lettres
par jour je les sélectionne
imaginons le cas se présente souvent may
cry on me une commerçante et raciste
vis-à-vis de sa clientèle j'appelle la
commerçante et je me vais passer pour le
service de voirie
je vais fermer la boutique on m'écrit
également en me disant qu'à proviseur de
lycée se comporte comme un tortionnaire
et bien je téléphone je fais ferme et
lycées pendant toute une journée en
prétextant n'importe quelle chose la
visite d'un ministre soviétique ou
n'importe quoi alors oui bonjour madame
service voirie municipale
oui nous appelons les commerçants de la
rue parce que nous leur répondons
d'éventuellement de penser à fermer
leurs magasins malheureusement mercredi
prochain
on nous a critiqués beaucoup sur cette
émission j'imagine en disant mais c'est
terrible c'est lacombe lucien c'est
l'occupation vous êtes des nazis on est
plus du côté de francis blanche
on est plus du côté du gaz téléphonique
peut-être mais pour la victimes comment
ça se passe après as à écouter cette
nuit c'est une question que je ne suis
jamais posée à vous de la zone fait un
reportage
qu'est ce qu'on ferait pas tout de même
pour faire grimper l'audience aussi on
n'a pas inauguré une nouvelle forme de
service public
carrément oui tout à fait moi je préfère
finalement que quelqu'un ait écrit à sky
man et entendu sur l'antenne de skyrock
sa vengeance en faisant à ce chien je
les ai eus je préfère ça que ils
défoncent la porte de la porte de son
voisin et qu'il assassine un coût de 22
long rifle et que ça fasse encore un
fait divers sordide
la punition vengeresse sa barre une
journée de fermeture
[Musique]